look he's put together I think an
exciting young team he's got some some
wisdom and experience there with with
with with rooney and Lampard but he's
got some great young players I'm sure
the whole country will get right behind
them and fingers crossed everything
cross for a great result what do you
think can they get out of their group
could they win the World Cup I you know
anything is possible and the whole point
about being in england fan is that
you've got to dare to dream and i will
definitely be daring to dream I'll be
shouting myself hoarse I was in a hotel
in Scotland last night talking to some
Scottish editors in there I'm sure I'm
sure you'll be right behind us do I'm
sure they will but you accept that point
that Prime Minister's fakes you can get
a bit of a bounce of England do well
well I i don't know i think sometimes
these things can be overwritten in the
end of the day my view is that people
treat elections in a very serious
fashion you know and they answered the
question in front of them the question I
was saying yesterday the question in
front of the Scottish people is you know
in the United Kingdom or out of the
United Kingdom not Alex Salmond's fate
or my fate the question at the next
election will not be how do you feel
about the England Football team or the
football manager it will be drawn to
stick to the long-term economic plan
it's delivering for Britain or do you
want to hand the keys back to the people
who crash the car in the first place the
Labour Party you want to borrow and
spend and tax that will be the question
and I think people address elections in
a pretty serious way in our country